[Music]
thank you everyone
who's joined in today i really
appreciate your time
and and hope that this can be a
productive time for all of us as we
spend some time talking about
r and plumber together as robert
mentioned my name is james blair i work
as a solutions engineer for our studio
and we're joined on the line today by
barry schlerke who also works
here at our studio and is the primary
maintainer of the plumber package
and is here to help with questions and
and provide some some support that way
as well so we're grateful for
his presence as well as we get started
today
our topic today is expanding our
horizons integrating r with plumber apis
the idea here is
i i'm hopeful that this really is an
opportunity for
if you've never been exposed to plumber
before i hope you find something that's
useful
and if you've used plumber in the past
and have come to kind of see what's new
with plumber i also hope that there's
something useful so the ideal state here
is that everyone walks away with
something
that's beneficial for them and and that
that they feel like they've learned
uh just to kind of give you an idea of
what we're going to do today first i
want to set the stage with a problem
that we're going to look at to
kind of to kind of frame the
conversation that we have and then we'll
have a brief discussion about what an
api is
in case you're unfamiliar and then we'll
talk about how you get started using
apis
with r and the plumber package and then
we'll spend some time discussing some of
the new features
that have been recently released in the
latest cran version of plumber
and then finally we'll conclude by
looking at different ways that you can
deploy these apis
so they can be widely utilized either
inside of your organization or
by a broader audience and then at the
end i'll provide some links to
additional resources
and like robert mentioned this is being
recorded uh today's october 28
2020 so if you're watching this
recording down the road um
things may have changed in the in the
plumber package and i'll
share some links here at the end that
can make sure you stay up to date with
the latest changes and things like that
but
resources will be provided if you if you
want to learn more
today we're going to work with a data
set this is the palmer penguins data set
um if you're unfamiliar this is a fairly
kind of recent to the r space data set
you can find some more information at
allison horse github repository that i
have linked here in the slides
but basically the idea here is we have
344 different
observations for three different penguin
species chin strap gentoo and the sedeli
and these different and this is if
you're familiar with kind of the iris
data set that the typical kind of
classification
data set that you often see this is a
similar style
data set right fairly easy to understand
down here on the
on the bottom right hand corner you can
see kind of a preview of what this data
looks like we've got the species the
island they came from
then we have some different measurements
from each of these different penguins
their bill length
build depth flipper length body mass and
then we have the sex of the penguin and
then the year that the measurement took
place so
what we want to do here is just kind of
frame this and this could be any data
set right this isn't
the example that we walked through today
is not specific to this data set by any
stretch of the imagination but i think
like most most data science most
analytical problems or projects start
with some data and that felt like a
natural place to start today let's start
with some data
and and and go from there so what we
want to do now is we you know
let's say we've been handed this data
and and we're going to go ahead and
we're going to
do the data science or in some cases you
know
that means build the model and we're
going to take
this these 345 observations this is not
a
a model building or necessarily you know
data science themed webinar so this is
not about how to build the best model
possible this is just let's work with an
example that that's easy for us to
understand so
we'll take the data you know we might
explore it clean it up a little bit
and then we'll fit this model to it and
the idea here is given some set of
measurements so given
the bill length the build up the flipper
length and the body mass
we want to predict the species of that
particular penguin
right and so that's what we've done in
the example that we have pulled up on
screen we fit this model
using the tidy models framework and then
we're able to see some output from that
model
and now that we have this we can
generate new predictions
right we can given a set of new data
maybe we get a new set of measurements
from a penguin of unknown species and we
want to predict what the species of that
penguin is
we can pass those new values through to
the model and generate a predicted
outcome in terms of
what species we we think is is that
penguin is likely to be
now this is all great but the question
now is kind of well now what right
we we have a couple of options now now
that we've
done our work we've built this model we
have a few options ahead of us one is
we can just kind of ad hoc score
new penguin predictions whenever we
receive new data right so maybe once a
month we get an email from researchers
that are off
researching penguins and they send us
their new set of data and we run that
set of data
through the model in order to predict
the species of these new measurements
um that works right but maybe we want
something that's a little bit more
real-time maybe there's maybe
measurements are happening at a pretty
rapid rate and we don't want our entire
day job from here on out to be
predicting penguin species using the
model that we built
right but we also don't want the model
that we built to just kind of wither
away and die we spent a lot of time here
this was something that we feel like
contributes to the the goals of our
business or the goals of the project
that we're working on
and we want to make sure that it
continues to contribute in the best way
possible
but the problem is we're kind of stuck
because
we either have to be the ones that
generate new values and new predictions
because we're the ones that built the
model and we
know how to use r or we have to find
somebody else that
knows r and can do that themselves right
so we maybe we email them or we
provide them with access to the model
and they're able to generate their own
predictions
but that's still kind of a high bar
because that means that that person
needs to be able to
open up an r session and load our model
and load the data and run the data
through the model
which if you're an r user that's
probably not that big of a deal but if
you're trying to teach one of the
business users or one of the end users
of your model
how to run this and you've got to teach
them about r now all of a sudden
this becomes a much larger task the
other option is
we could just pass this off to somebody
else we could say okay we've done our
job
here's the model here's kind of how we
set this up now
let's let that model grow up
quote-unquote and we'll give it to
an engineering team and they'll
reconstruct this model
in a framework that they're using so
that it can be
used for real-time scoring or real-time
predicting
of new data and that that's a totally
valid option
but it's often a little bit tricky to
get that right
right to be able to hand off the model
in that way it's time consuming
it can be you know it can be a difficult
process to go through
when in reality we already have
everything we need what we really need
is just a convenient way for other
people
to be able to use our model and that's
really where apis come in so let's
let's take a step aside from the model
for a moment and let's just talk about
this notion of what an api is and in
general
the an api stands for application
programming interface
now that can mean a lot of different
things and in different contexts
the idea of an api can mean different
things which makes it a little bit
difficult to understand
and so for the purpose of our
conversation today
we're going to narrow in on this
definition that we can
that an api is a a web api communicating
over http
um and basically what that is is that
provides us with a standardized way
for different com for different
computers to communicate with one
another
right that's the and i'm not going to
dive into the nitty-gritty details of
what makes up an api request and what a
response looks like there's lots of
different features involved here
that you can look into and that and that
will provide some resources that provide
some detail there
but the main idea is when we talk about
web apis
over http which is what we're going to
talk about today
this is just a standardized set way for
different computers to communicate just
like
i'm communicating now through my voice
and and
you're able to understand computers have
their own way of communicating
http web apis is one of those mechanisms
for communication
the idea is there's a client that sends
a request
that request meets the standard of what
the
the server is expecting and then a
server receives that request and then
generates some sort of a response
and that response could be something as
simple as i received a request
that's all that's all i need that's all
i need to do to something that's much
more complex like firing off some sort
of process or updating a database or
generating predictions against the model
or any number of different things
can happen in response to a request that
comes in
but the server is responsible for taking
the request and doing something with it
and then providing a response
and even if you've never really
interacted directly
knowingly with apis in the past um
it's it's interesting to note that
anytime you use a a web browser so if
you use google chrome or safari or
brave or firefox or anything like that
and you visit a website
there's a there's a request that your
web browser makes to a server that says
hey i'd like to view this
web page that's con that's at this
address and the server responds with
typically a bunch of html that your
browser then renders for you to view so
anytime you view a website
you're really interacting with apis even
if you don't acknowledge that fact
right your computer is a client and it's
sending a request
and there's a server somewhere that's
responding to that request with
some html that you view as the webpage
now this is again not meant to be a
comprehensive overview of what apis are
or how apis work
um but this hopefully sets the stage and
gives you a little bit of background
and the next general question i think
that makes that that makes sense to ask
here is
okay well that's that's great but as an
r user
as a statistician as an actuary as a
data scientist
as an analyst why do i care
right why is this something that's
important to me and
i think there's kind of two reasons here
that this becomes significant and it
goes back to
our initial conundrum where we've built
this model
and we want to give people access to it
but we don't want to train the whole
company on how to use r
right and the fact is apis allow the
work that you do
to be used by a wide range of tools and
technologies
and that and that that that's no longer
no longer limited
to just the r language okay
so i can now essentially say okay i've
got this
model that we're going to work with and
we'll walk through an example of this in
just a moment but i got this model here
um and i've got another team in my
organization that's using
python or they're using c sharp or
they're using javascript or they're
using c
plus are they using any number of tools
and they want to use my model
well apis allow me to do that in a very
very straightforward and easy way
so that i no longer need to hand off my
model to be
rebuilt by another team in another
language but instead they can just
communicate directly with
the work that i've done via this this
web api
and this again the idea here is this
dramatically reduces the handoff
between the work that you do in r and
other tools that are being built
within your organization by teams using
other languages or other
technology frameworks so with that kind
of
in mind let's talk briefly about how
plumber works and how plumber creates
this bridge between
our users and developers and other tools
and technologies
here's an example of a plumber api over
here on the left hand side of the screen
and i want us to i'm going to walk
through some of the core components here
but before i do that if you just take a
step back and ignore the comments
right so if you just ignore the
commented lines of code or the commented
lines in this r code
it should look pretty straightforward if
you've written our code before we've got
a couple of functions that we define
and we load the plumber package at the
top of this of the script
and if i look at these functions there's
nothing that's terribly
you know interesting or different about
them if i look at the first function
over here
it takes a single parameter message and
then it returns a list
just that verifies that it received the
messages essentially right it returns a
list that says okay the message is
and then it echoes back that message my
second function here doesn't take any
arguments and instead it just returns
a histogram of some random values that i
drew from the normal distribution
so it's pretty easy to reason about what
these two functions will do
right function one is going to echo back
whatever i give it function 2 is going
to give me a random
histogram of some values now the real
i think the real magic and the real
power of the plumber package is how it
allows
me to go from these simple r functions
to a responsive web api in just a couple
of comments
and that's where these comments come
into play so if you focus on what i have
highlighted here in this box
you'll notice that these comments look a
little bit different than standard r
comments i've got the the
pound similar the hashtag symbol that's
what is typically used to comment things
in r
but then i follow that with an asterisk
and that indicates the plumber hey this
is a special comment
that provides instructions for what
plumber needs to do
and so i can see for example if i take
this first comment
i give it this api title tag and i know
that because it starts with the at
symbol and then api title
and then i give the api some sort of a
name plumber example api in this case
and then the next comment block these
three comments following
describe how plumbers should use the
function that comes afterwards
so first comment here tells me it gives
a description of what this
function is going to do it's going to
echo back the input
my second comment here describes the
parameters of that function so in this
case i have a single message parameter
that parameter is the message that i'm
going to echo
and then the final line here is perhaps
the most important because it defines
both what types of requests this will
respond to
as well as what path this particular
function
is listening on and so essentially what
this says is okay if i run this
as an api and i make some sort of a
request
to the echo path you see this slash echo
here
then what i'm going to get back is i'm
going to get back the response
of this function and whatever this
function does that will be returned
to whatever client makes a request at
this echo endpoint
and and to be even more specific
that client will make a get request
which we've denoted with this get
tag here so the idea is
i write standard r code as functions
i use these special comments to identify
how plumbers should handle those
functions
and then i run the api or i plumb it
right and and you can see here
in this little screenshot i've got this
run api button and in practice what this
looks like
is this i click run api i'll get this
nice little window that pops open over
here that shows me the api running
and then i can try this out i can say
okay here's my my message
is hello world i'm going to go ahead and
try that out
and if we scroll down we can see that
the output of that message
is the out or the output of that of that
execution is the output
of the function that i wrote in r okay
so again if i look at this try this out
write my message hello world and then
here at the bottom we'll see
some json that comes back that contains
the output of my function message the
messages hello world
and it really is that simple right now
what i've done is i've taken my
functions in r
and i've made them so that they're
easily accessible from other tools
and other frameworks so let's actually
take a look at this and let's consider
our our original kind of situation here
we've got this model that we built using
this penguin data set
and what we want to do now is we want to
see okay is there a way for us to expose
this model
so that others can interact with it is
there a way for us to
essentially say okay what if a client
makes a request
with new data could we just respond
with the predicted outcomes could we
just respond with the predicted species
given that request and and do that
automatically so that
you know if if somebody you know in
another department has a python script
that wants to use our model they can
just send a request
with new data and we can send them back
the predicted outcome
that's what we want to accomplish here
so let's actually i'm going to flip over
here to our studio now
and let's go ahead and let's build this
out okay so what we want to do is we
want to
load the plumber package
and then before i do anything else um
let's let's
just kind of make sure that we've got
the pieces in place
that we want to have in place so what
i'm going to do first here is i'm going
to create i'm going to zoom in a little
bit
i'm going to create just a single
endpoint
that all it does is just verifies that
things are working it's not going to do
anything other than just return some
information that says hey
the lights are on things seem to be
working so we'll call this
um we'll write the function here if i
could type
and we'll say we want to return a list
and we want to say okay the status
is that all is good
and then we'll return the time just so
we can verify that this is
working the way that it that it should
okay and if i
and if i run this function we could call
this function um
status or something like that and if i
run
this function in r we can see what i get
back
i get back this list and it tells me the
status is all good and it gives me this
time stamp of when that
when that function executed and now what
i want to do is i want to turn this into
a an api endpoint so we'll give it a
little description here we'll say
um we'll call this help check
um let's call this health check right
is the api running okay so that's our
description
and then this will respond to get
requests
at the help check panel
right so i've taken i've written my
function and now all i'm doing is i'm
adding these special comments that we
saw before
that tell plumber what to do with this
function right what do i want to do well
i want to
call it health check this is the title
the description i'm going to give it
and then here's the important piece that
says okay whenever a get request comes
in
and i'm not going to get into what
different request types are and things
like that that's
that's an exercise for another time but
essentially if a request comes into this
location
then return the results of this function
execute this function and return the
results
and and if we save this we can click run
api here
and we'll see over here on the right
hand side we've got this little
interface that shows up that allows us
to see okay we've got this
health check let me expand this out a
little bit so we can see all right
so here i've got this get health check
it tells me the description of the
of the endpoint which is what we
provided right here is the api running
health check is the api running
and we can try this out let's come in
and try this out there's no parameters
i don't need to provide any parameters
here so i can just execute this
and here i see my response body and i
can see directly
in fact let's see if we can make this a
little easier to compare
if i scroll up up here here we go
here's the result of my function in r
right we ran the function in r and
that's what we see
and here is the result when i make a
request
an api request to this endpoint and
hopefully you can see the connection
between the two right i here
up top i've got an r list that was
created that tells me the status and the
time
and here down below i have that same
list
except now it's just in json format
which is
the kind of the industry standard for
how these apis communicate now you can
adjust
how this what type of response this an
api generates and we'll look at that
here in a little bit
but by default plumber will take the
output of your function
and convert it to json and that json
data will be returned
to the client so here's what we here's
what we saw returned to the client
and basically what this says is okay we
have this working right plumber's
working
we're able to see that the api is
running we can try this out again if we
wanted to right we could execute this
again
and we see the same result but the time
stamp is now updated to reflect the
current time
which in my local time is 11 23 am okay
all right we're going to stop the api
and now we're going to keep going so
this
this make sure that okay we've got all
the pieces in place we know what we're
doing
now let's figure out okay what do we
really want to do what's our goal
here well first of all i need the model
so i've already saved the model we'll
just read the model in
we'll say model is read um
model okay so i've got this model off
file that i've already saved
we can read this in here all right so
we've got our model
and now what i want to be able to do is
i want to say okay what if i if i
predict
my model and i say new data is and i've
got some
json data lying around so i'll say
free json penguins
okay and i'll say type equals prob okay
so let's see oh we need to do
there we go all right so now if i look
at this and i'll walk through what we
did here but if i look what i really
want is i wanted to say okay
given my model that i already trained i
want to be able to give it some new data
and return the predicted outcomes
so in this case what i'm returning is
i'm returning a pre a probability value
for each of the three different species
right so in this case penguin one has a
strong we're
almost entirely confident there's gen
two um prediction two
or observation two we're very strongly
predicting that it's
a delhi so on and so forth i can see the
breakdown across each
potential outcome or each potential
species here
in my output so this works this is i
mean this is how i would generate new
predictions in
r but what i really want is i really
want this functionality
to take place in an api i want somebody
to be able to just
pass me some data and then i can pass
them back the predicted outcomes
like like what i'm doing here in r so
this is this is our goal right here our
goal is to do this
is to have this kind of behavior in an
api endpoint so
we've got our model in place we'll need
to let's bring in we've got a couple of
other
um packages that we'll need to make sure
that they're available in our
environment here
just for the model so we need to bring
in the parsnip package
for the predict function to work the
right the way that we want it to and
this is all because of how we train the
model
and then we want to bring in the ranger
package because we trained this model
using
the ranger package so so this is again
just to remind ourselves
this is a random forest model that we
built we saved it out
and now we're going to use it in this
api that we're building
okay i've got these pieces in place so
now what i want is i want to say okay
i've got a function
and and what i want to be able to do is
i want to say okay i want to predict
i've already got my model
because i've loaded that in my
environment so i've got my model and
then
i've got new data and this is the part
okay
now i got to figure this out because
where is this data gonna come from
right i don't have like like when i run
this as an api
i want this data to come from the user
right this is the this is this is data
that comes from the client request
okay so okay let's think about how that
works the way that this works in plumber
is i'm gonna have i'm gonna write my
function so that it takes a couple of
arguments
uh request req and response oh yes
and what this does if i write my
function this way it allows me to have
access to the full request that's being
made from within my function plumber
will automatically pass that
that request object into my function and
then i have access to it
and one of the cool things with plumber
with the with the latest release of
plumber
is that you could you can automatically
parse
incoming data and make it available
in the request itself so so for example
if i have a user that makes a request
with some json data
and says okay here's here's some here's
some information about some new penguins
we found
and i want to know what their what their
species is so they make this request
plumber will automatically take that
json data convert it to a data frame
and make it available for me to use
within the body of this function
that i'm writing right now so all we
need to know is we need to know okay
well what
what like where where does that get
stored and it gets stored as the request
as part of the request and it gets
stored as the body object
attached to this incoming request and in
fact
we'll take a look at that in just a
moment but this is this is essentially
what i want to be able to do i want to
say okay let's do this
and let's say um type is probability
like we saw before right we're just
we're just taking this
this function that was our goal and
we're we're now
putting it inside this function that
we're going to use within our api
so we're going to say this is going to
be predict species for new penguins
okay and then this is let's say
we want to respond to post requests
at the predict endpoint okay
excellent let's um let's let's go ahead
and run this
i'm going to go i'm going to go ahead
and comment this out just because this
isn't a necessary piece of what we're
doing this is just
so that we know what we're trying to
accomplish here um we're gonna run this
api
and let's pop this open over here okay
so we see our health check let's just
verify that that's doing what we think
it should be and it looks like it is
which is great that means everything's
working on the plumber side as far as we
know
and then let's take a look at our
predict
endpoint here okay we've got this
predict endpoint we'll try it out
okay execute okay we get some sort of
error here
okay and if we look at this this is just
an r error that's come back to us
in json format right which is again a
nice kind of feature of a plumber is
that
if my r code throws an error i can
capture that error and i can gracefully
return something to the user or if i
don't capture it or do anything like
that
then plumber will automatically take
that error message
convert it into json and return it back
to the user so they get some idea of
what's going on
and what's really happening here is i
like i didn't give this any data
so this is saying look i didn't find you
know one or more independent variables
was not found
um like i didn't find any data and that
actually makes sense because i didn't i
didn't give it any data in here
right like i didn't there wasn't any
part of this where i like provided it
with some
sample data um and so now i've got to
figure out okay well how do i
how can i provide some sample data here
right and one of the one of the features
that's new
to plumber is the ability to modify
the user interface that appears okay so
we saw this user interface that showed
up over here in fact let me just run
this one more time so we can see it
right so i've got this user interface
that appears over here this
is really really nice because it means
that as an r user when i'm building my
api
and i run it i get a nice really clean
way
to interact with the api directly from
within our studio
right right here in our studio i can
check to see that my api is working and
here we go
right things are working i can check
this endpoint
but as we just saw if i try to do
something like check this endpoint
all of a sudden i'm in a little bit of a
bind because there's nothing here that
allows me to pass in data
so what i really would like is i'd like
somebody to say okay like
how can i like can i just plop some json
in here
right like instead of instead of not
being able to do anything what if i
could just
drop some json into here and and run it
that way
and with the newest release of plumber
that is entirely possible
so that entire user interface that we're
just looking at
is built around something called the
open api specification now
the entire open api specification is
a massive standardization standardized
format for
defining api behavior and
endpoints and things like that i am not
going to spend
a lot of time going into the entirety of
what open api is and all that entails
um you're certainly welcome to look more
into that on your own but what it means
for us
as our users and as plumber users is
that if we want to enhance the
capability of our of our user interface
here
we can do so by doing one of two things
we can either
modify it directly in r um
by by modifying a list a massive list
or we can provide our own specification
file
and use that from within rn so that's
that's what we're going to do here
and i'll show you what this looks like
so i'm going to create another little
section here
and we're going to call this app plumber
this is another new feature of the
package
and basically what this special tag does
is it allows me to take my existing
plumber object and modify it however i
want
okay so i'm no longer defining an
endpoint but rather what i'm doing is
i'm saying okay after i've done all this
stuff so after i've added health check
after i've added predict i want to
further modify this
object that's being created and so i'm
going to say this is a function
of and we'll call it pr for my plumber
router
and then in here i can modify what
what i want to do to this pr object and
and this gives me another chance to
unveil one more
really great feature of the newest
release of plumber and that is
i can now do something like this pr pipe
pr set api spec
and i want to say okay let's i've got
this yaml file that i'm going to read
and i'll show you what this file looks
like in just a moment here
um okay so let's before we look at this
yaml file let's look at what we're doing
here
i'm saying okay plumber take this
information and start building me
an api router but now that you've built
these pieces so you've got this endpoint
you've got this endpoint i want to do
something else to it
i want to take that router and i want to
add
this api specification file right
and so what i can do here is i can
either provide a named list which this
will do
or i can modify the existing
specification that plumber is already
building for me
either one works i kind of like this
approach because it allows me to lay out
the whole
outline of what i want and that can be
helpful but either one works so if we
look at this open api
file here this is a yaml file that just
contains
information about the api and notice
i define like the summary for my health
check i define the summary for predict
and if i run this now we come back over
here to my plumber file
and we run this you'll notice
that my descriptions have now changed
right my health check says determine if
the api is running and listening as
expected
and notice that here my description says
health check is the api running
well why are those two things different
they're different
because i overwrite in this yaml file
what that description should be notice
in here i say determine if the api is
running and listening as expected
and that is what we see listed in in my
interface
okay so i have effectively overwritten
some of what i already did by providing
this new definition file
but in addition to overwriting some of
that information i've also described
that i want to be able to pass in json
data to this predict endpoint
and so if i come over here and open this
up it tells me here look the request
body
should be json and here's an example of
what that json data should look like
and if i try this out i can come in here
and i can edit this i could say well
what if we said 51
10 or what if we said 54 40 or 55 40 or
whatever the case is
right i can come in and i can pass my
own data
into this endpoint now and try it out
right we can execute this
and here we see that we have once again
an internal error and this is because if
we come back over to our
api file for just a moment we're passing
in only a single value
and it's being parsed as a vector
instead of a data frame so if we just
change this one piece
and say we want this to be a data frame
now let's run the api one more time
try this out here's our data that we're
passing in let's execute on that data
and here we see our response is a json
object that contains
the predicted probability for each
associated species so in this case this
particular penguin is almost a toss up
right we're not super sure which one it
is maybe it's chin strap but it's
it's a fairly even split across all
three potential outcomes here
and what's great about this is now we
have
exactly what we were describing
originally right if i come back up here
for just a moment
and look at what my goal was right i
want to i want to enable
an external user to give me some data
and then i want to be able to return to
them the associated likelihood
that that particular set of data matches
up with each of the three species that
are
our potential outcomes and that's
exactly what i've done here
now to recap right just to revisit this
this idea one more time
we have specified our own specification
file
this yaml file that identifies
all the details of how this user
interface should be laid out
and that's where i can that's what
that's what enables me to have
the ability to input the json data
needed
to generate a response from this
endpoint
okay so all from within rstudio itself
i'm able to build my api and i'm able to
come over here
and verify that that api is working the
way that it that it needs to
okay that's been a little bit to swallow
i know that's you know maybe we've we've
gotten into some detail that we didn't
necessarily
need to or want to get into but i think
it's useful to understand how some of
these pieces work
is it necessary to change the api
specification file no
is it something that you have to do no
right you can you can do this
you can operate just fine without it um
now granted
that might mean that you need to find
some other way to make a request
to your api um to verify that your
predict endpoint is working the way that
you expect
um but there are lots of tools that that
work that will
enable you to interact with apis in a
really nice kind of
clean interface uh postman is one that i
use regularly and there are several
others that exist
as well that allow you to generate
requests and see responses and things
like that so
do you need to make these modifications
no but if you want to
you certainly can let's take a look at
one more thing here that i think is
is again maybe a little bit extra but i
think it's it's useful to know
the default interface i'm going to run
this api one more time
the default interface here is swagger
and i see that
up here in the top left-hand corner this
is the swagger interface um
swagger it has been around for quite a
while
open api the specification kind of grew
out of some of the efforts that went
into swagger and everything like that
but essentially now what we have is
swagger is a is
will interpret my specification and give
me
this interface okay there are other
alternatives to swagger that exist today
that do the same thing
that create an interface for me to use
and now within plumber
given the latest release it's entirely
possible to use one of those other
systems
instead of using swagger itself so for
example if i wanted to use there's a
there's a
library or a viewer called rapidoc so if
i wanted to use rapidoc i could come in
here
there's an r package it's not released
on crayon it's only on github at this
point but there's an artifact it's
called rapidoc
that i could install here or that i
could load here
and then further down i could say let's
do pr
set docs and we'll say docs
is the dock okay
we'll save these changes and now if i
come back and run my api again
you'll see that my interface looks
different i have the same functionality
right i can open up
this one i can try this out i can see
the response
i can open up this one come in here i
can see the example data i can try this
out
we see the response right so again my
functionality remains the same
but maybe i have a preference over which
particular ui i use when i'm
experimenting with and
and and working with my apis and you
have the flexibility now and plumber to
be able to define those
uh one more thing that i want to look at
here is while we've got this open
we have this built-in example here that
gives us a sing the measurements for a
single penguin
but i've also got this java excuse me
this this json data here
that contains measurements for several
penguins and if we copy this
in here and try this out
we'll see that our response now includes
predicted output for
all the penguins that i provided input
for right so i now have this long
json object that contains all the
information for the penguins that i
provided
okay let's look at one more thing here
let's come back
into my um plumber file
and let's say okay instead of json
though let's say i just i really want
i really want csv data to come out of
this
right so we could say at serializer csv
this tells plumber look when you return
the output of this function
don't return it as json return it as a
csv file
and if i run this again or return this
to csv data and if i run this again
and try this let's bring in all of our
observations again
you can see now instead of this json
object i have comma separated values
for my response right so i can adjust
what specifically is returned to the
client from within here
okay we're going to take a step back
from this for a moment we'll revisit our
api here in just a minute
let's go ahead and stop this we'll save
these changes here um and let's come
back towards
to our slides okay so just to recap and
and
kind of summarize what we looked at here
several new features
have landed in the plumber package with
the latest release
the tidy interface so so the ability to
build your apis by piping from one
command to the next
is new um we barely touched on that but
that's something that you can explore
more if you're interested
the ability to automatically parse and
parse
the incoming request body so that it's
available for
downstream execution is new which we saw
that when we said okay
the request body contains the parsed
values that we're getting from the
client
there's support for new serializers and
the way that you define serializers is
greatly simplified
uh the open api specification we looked
at you can adjust that
in a couple of different ways by either
providing your own file or by
modifying the existing list that r is
working with you can customize the ui
so instead of using swagger which is the
default you can use rapidoc you could
use
redoc there's a handful of different
custom uis you can use
and last but not least plum the plumber
hex logo has gotten a facelift
this was on the title slide so you
probably already come across it but
there's the new plumber logo
that um that accompanies this this
update that's happened
okay so now we've got this api it's
running
it's doing what we want we've mission
accomplished right we're able to take
in some data we're able to generate
predictions we're able to return that
data
back to the client all is good except
for one thing
we are still the bottleneck right like
this is like
i'm just working off my laptop right now
and so when i'm running this api
it's just running locally here on my own
machine
and that works for development purposes
and testing purposes
but what happens when i now want to say
look
sarah in engineering is ready to make a
request to this api
well i don't want my laptop to always to
be the one thing that's servicing these
requests i need some way to deploy this
so that it's in an environment where
it's always listening and available
to clients that are trying to make that
request again whether those clients are
other
parts of my organization or maybe i've
built an api that's just
generally publicly available and is
being used by who knows who
there are a couple of options that exist
for deploying plumber apis
rstudio connect is a professional
product that's developed and built by
our studio
that allows for easy deployment of
plumber apis we'll look at an example of
that here in just a moment
you can deploy you can wrap up these
apis inside of a docker container and
then
deploy them into an environment that's
suitable for that type of deployment
uh and then there's some nice kind of
helper functions that used to exist
in the plumber package and have now been
offloaded to a new package called
plumber deploy
that allow you to easily deploy to
digitalocean and that that package may
evolve to include
other deployment endpoints as well so
we've got a host of different options
i want to spend a couple of minutes just
to talk about rstudio connect
as as one potential way of deploying
these plumber apis
uh our studio connect is like i
mentioned it's a
professional product that we create and
develop here at our studio
it allows for easy push button
deployment of things created in r
and python it handles dependency
management so all of your
packages and dependencies come along for
the ride it allows you to adjust how
your api
scales how it responds to concurrent
requests how new processes are generated
things of that nature
it integrates with git and github so
that you can automatically deploy from
repositories you can specify who has
permission and authentication to access
things like apis and dashboards and
things like that
and then like i said in addition to
plumber you can also publish our
markdown documents and reports shiny
applications jupiter notebooks
flask dash streamlet python applications
and
other additional other additional pieces
of content
and if you'd like to learn more you can
visit our our website
studio.com product connect which details
what our studio connect is and provides
a little bit of additional context
but what i'd like to do now is i'd like
to take a look at our studio connect
so if i come here this is rstudio
connect
uh let's come in to kind of the landing
page here so here's what i see when i
come into
rstudio connect something like this and
let's let's
go through the process of publishing
this api that we built
now i've set up this api that we built
in in
in our studio to be publishable via git
so if i come in here
and say okay let's let's import this
from a git repository
let's pull in the repository name so
that is
um let's see
okay so here's the repository for that i
had to find it really quick
um so github.com i've got this
repository that i keep
talks and things that i do in and then
this is the plumber webinar 2020
repository click next here
this will look to see what branches are
available i've only got a single branch
available there right now click next and
then this will look for
deployable subdirectories in this case
we only have one
it's looking for this manifest file that
i previously created
and then we'll call this plumber
pangolins okay deploy content
and now this is deploying our content
here we go let's open this up and see
what it looks like
okay so here we have our api running
i can open this up and say okay let's
you know anybody can come in here and
view this if they want to
um here's my health check let's verify
that this is working
looks like it is gives me back the
information that i expect
let's check out our our other endpoint
our predict endpoint
it looks like it's doing what we want it
to do there we go we see our csv output
here
and all is well and good right i've got
everything everything is working the way
that i expect it to
and just to kind of illustrate this
right if i so
one one way to to quickly and easily
demonstrate how
an external either tool or framework or
language can make a request to this api
if i open this api up here um
there we go let's take a look at this so
now i've i've opened this up so that
it's just
open kind of in its own isolated
environment and if i instead of going to
docs
go to help check and this might be a
little small to see and i apologize but
i'm just visiting the url and then
adding
health check to the end of it and
basically what this means is my browser
is now going to make a request to the
health check endpoint
and if we do this my browser shows me
the json
that's coming back from that health
check endpoint
so without any sort of like fancy bells
and whistles
i've just now made a request to this api
from my web browser
and i'm now seeing the results of that
request rendered here
in front of us okay
so last thing that i want to highlight
here before we wrap things up
all is well and good right my api is
running i can give
other developers or other teams within
my organization
i can give them the information they
need to make requests this api
they can make those requests my api will
respond back to them
and all is good but now let's say okay i
publish this it's great
and then i get an email in a couple days
that says look we started using and
interacting with your api
uh we noticed that it's giving us back
uh comma separated values
right and we'd really prefer to get json
like we can parse the csv data but our
platform's built around json could you
provide us with json
as a response instead of these comma
separated values
and and we've already seen how to do
that right if we come back into
our studio here and and take a look
right if we come
if we take this serializer and say
instead of
csv let's just do json and json json's
the default right so if i deleted this
whole thing
it would still be json but we could we
could save this change
and we say okay we're going to we're
going to return json data here
um let's go ahead and save that and then
let's come in
to if i can pull it open there we go
let's come in to get
and make and commit this change we'll
say okay we're gonna
uh we're gonna uh update to json
serialize
serialization okay commit that
we'll go ahead and push this change to
github
and now let's go ahead and grab our big
collection of penguins and if we come
back over here our studio connect will
check every 15 minutes or so by default
to see what changes have been made to
the repository
um but i i'm also just going to kind of
manually kick it off and say okay let's
just check for any updates in the
repository
hey some changes were found we're going
to redeploy this
okay we're ready to go
and now if i come in
and try this endpoint out and we'll
change our example to include
all this we can see that my response is
now
json instead of csv and i didn't have to
do anything all i did was
make a change and commit that change to
my github repository like i'd normally
do in my regular workflow
and r studio connect will automatically
pick up on that change redeploy the
content
and make it available so that i can make
the change push it to github
and email that developer back and say it
should be fixed now you should now be
able to receive json
all right so in conclusion
uh if you're interested in learning more
about plumber and
the tools that we've talked about today
here's a whole list of resources you can
go to visit
uh the first list the first resource
listed here is the plumber website
and then a bunch of different github
repositories so the plumber github
repository if you
run into like issues or questions with
the package
um you can go there to see if that issue
has already been uh submitted or you can
submit your own issue
this second repository listed here is a
collection of
just example apis to kind of build from
if you are looking for some examples to
get started with
uh plumber deploy i briefly mentioned
currently has the digital ocean
functions for
deploying a digital ocean this rapidoc
repository is something we used today so
that we could change the user interface
that we saw with plumber
the material that we looked at today so
the example files and everything like
that the slides
will be made available at the webinars
github repository
that's listed here so look for that to
be uh
published there shortly uh and then the
community the rc
community site has a plumber group or a
plumber tag that you can follow
if you're interested in questions being
asked about plumber if you have
questions on your own that you'd like to
ask to the community
you can do so there and then finally um
our
our studio has our global uh conference
coming up in
in january uh barrett who's again joined
us today
is is going to be presenting some
additional new functionality with
plumber and asynchronous execution
at that and that's an entirely virtual
conference that you can attend and i
would encourage you to attend as well
especially if you're interested
in asynchronous plumber execution as
that is what barrett is going to be
speaking about there
uh and then finally just thank you again
for your time for joining us today
i i appreciated this opportunity to
present on plummer
and all the new features that we've
added to the package we're really
excited about the work that's being done
if you have questions if you have you
know things you want to discuss
feel free to reach out reach out on our
studio community i monitor that site
quite frequently and respond to
questions or comments that are posted
there
and again just from all of us here at
our studio thank you very much for
joining us today
i think we've got a couple of minutes
here for questions
and so i'm going to kind of pause and
pull open the questions here to see if
there's anything
that um that remains to be answered
uh there's a question that came in that
says are there any suggested
suggested tools or packages to integrate
security
uh to secure access to apis really good
question
there's not anything on like the r
package standpoint
that i've really tested i know that a
while ago and i'm trying to remember the
name
i came across a group that was building
an r package
that the goal was to provide security
some security functionality for plumber
apis i haven't revisited that in quite a
while and
in fact like i said i don't quite
remember what the name of that
repository or package was going to be so
i don't know where things ended up there
i don't know how far that made it
um because of plumber's flexibility you
can handle
like security and and authentication and
things like that yourself it becomes
i don't want to say tricky but it just
you have to think carefully about it to
make sure that you don't leave yourself
open to like security vulnerabilities
but you could certainly
for example have a filter in place that
says look if a use if a request is made
without a specific header or without a
specific token
then that that doesn't get passed
through that request gets rejected
and and 404 is out or something like
that you can certainly do that
on your own within plumber but there's
no like i said
to my knowledge there's no kind of
out-of-the-box package or tool that does
that for you
that being said rstudio connect does
have
um api key-based authentication so if i
for example take my let me just come
back here for just a minute
if i take my my little api here and set
it and instead said look
you have to log in to view this then
that would require users to submit a
request with an api key as one of their
headers
and rcdo connect will verify that key
and verify that the key belongs to a
user that
is allowed permission to this api and
then pass that through
but again that's something that's
enforced on our studio connect level and
not being enforced at the plumber level
plumber's still just responding as
usual our studio connect is acting as
the gatekeeper in front of it to
filter out requests that are invalid
it's a great question
uh can you completely customize the look
of the api that makes it look prettier
for users are you stuck with the
templates you showed
so those templates so we looked at
swagger we looked at rapidoc
those are based off of the open api
specification basically what those do
those are frameworks that take that open
api specification which was basically
that big yaml file we looked at
and then generate a ui layer on top of
it and then
the nice thing about plumber is it
connects that ui layer to the underlying
r
process that's running the api right so
i've got this nice direct direct link
between okay i've got this api running
and now i can
interact with it like we see here right
i've got this nice sort of
ui layer um i'm not like i don't have a
lot of experience with each of those
individual pieces so for example we're
using rapidoc here right
i don't know how customizable the look
and feel of this particular
framework is there i do know that there
are
a handful of frameworks that exist today
and there's kind of more being created
almost it feels like all the time and so
it's possible that some may
provide additional flexibility i don't i
don't entirely know the answer to that
particular question uh can plumber
dictate rate limits
another excellent question not out of
the box there's nothing specific in
plumber where you can specify like you
know an a rate limit
tag or setting or anything like that you
could build in rate limiting yourself
it would require some additional leg
work because you'd have to have some way
of identifying you know
how are you rate limiting are you rate
limiting to a specific user and then
you'd have some sort of
cache where you keep track of what their
rate limit or what their current
consumption is and then check that
consumption against the limit that
they've been
given and provide messaging around that
limit
you can build all that in employment i'm
not saying that it's not possible i'm
just saying
there's not anything built in that
allows you to rate limit but you could
certainly build that functionality into
your apis
by using tools that plumber provides
okay yes okay so once deployed how do
you submit the new data to the model api
it seems unwieldy to just like pass in a
giant browser url
totally correct right in most cases
these apis aren't going to be interacted
with the
web browser but rather somebody else so
you maybe you've got a front-end
developer that's that's
writing javascript or you've got a
mobile app developer developing in swift
or whatever the case is
all of these frameworks have their own
libraries packages
tools for building and sending api
requests
and those developers would often do that
so for example as an r
user the hdtr package is what you would
use
to build a request so if you were in our
user submitting a request
to you i could submit a request to this
to this api we just built right
i could use the httr package to build
that request
including the the new data that's going
to be passed to the
to the predict endpoint and and send
that request over and then the response
will come back
and i could work with it from there so
in most cases the nice thing is
when you start talking about apis most
developers
uh will understand kind of how to work
with that and they'll have their own
framework that they use for sending
requests
and the nice thing is those requests
will all be formatted the same way
because
http is a standard format so your api it
doesn't matter if the request is coming
from
an r script using httr if it's coming
from python using the request module it
doesn't matter if it's coming from
golang it doesn't matter
it doesn't matter the request comes in
the api executes and returns the
response
um and lots of frameworks have their own
way of of
making those requests
okay um last question that i'll answer
here in the last minute that we've got
what is the advantage of using an r
api versus shiny apps uh really good
question
uh shiny applications are really best
suited for like human interaction right
so if i've got a shiny application
i'm gonna come in here and i'm gonna
interact with it as an individual
right as a as a api it's not necessarily
expected that
users are going to come in here and
interact with the api this way
they might do it a little bit right just
to kind of check some things but in most
cases an api is going to be interacted
with programmatically
so i might build a plumber api so that
another tool that my company developed
can use my model or can use the business
logic that i've implemented in my api
i might use a shiny app so that another
user
can view my model if that makes sense
right so the the distinction here is
who's the end user
in one case for shiny it's another human
that's interacting with my application
for apis it's most likely another tool
that's interacting with
with my application or with my api